Apple's latest based Mac books are of
really great value compared to last year
especially the base MacBook Pro which
now packs a powerful quad-core processor
the touch bar and the t2 chip and what's
most impressive is that it's still
priced at only $1300 and it performs
close to as well as the more expensive
eighteen hundred dollar model the
MacBook Air didn't really change much at
all since last year but it actually got
$100 cheaper so you may be asking what's
the catch how was Apple able to offer so
much more value this year and did they
have to sacrifice something the answer
is yes they did and it has to do with
the SSD storage after some testing with
the new 2019 MacBooks we found that the
storage transfer speeds have actually
gone down this year for example the 2017
$1300 MacBook Pro with the base 128
gigabyte SSD got around 2300 megabytes
per second read speed compared to only
around 1,300 megabytes per second on the
2019 based model that's a 1,000 megabyte
per second drop in speed and even if you
upgrade to the 256 gig SSD it's still
around a thousand megabytes per second
slower than the 256 gig on the $1,800
MacBook Pro which shows that only the
base model has been affected and we see
the same thing on the MacBook Air as
well this year's model dropped by around
600 megabytes per second reach speed
when comparing it to last year's 128 gig
SSD so we can clearly see that the SSDs
this year are definitely slower but the
biggest question that we have is will
the slower storage speeds negatively
impact the machines during day-to-day
use and if so by how much and even
though they're slower
are they still fast enough for most
people well for starters we compare the
$1300 base MacBook Pros SSD to Dells
brand new XPS 13 laptop with a 256 gig
SSD and we found that the MacBook was
actually still slightly faster than the
XPS and that's the story for most
Windows laptops packing SSDs that are
slower than the ones that come in Mac
books even with the speeds being slower
this year and interestingly if you grab
the base model and jump to a 256 gig SSD
or larger the write speeds actually go
significantly and that's because the
larger storage drives have more
individual NAND flash chips on them that
on the 128 gig SSD allowing them to work
together to provide faster write speeds
but the point of this testing is that
for many years
Apple was putting in top-of-the-line
SSDs which in my opinion were overkill
for most people especially on the base
models so to find out if those old SSDs
were actually overkill and if these new
ones are still fast enough we decided to
run a few tests to see if the extra SSD
speed actually makes a noticeable
difference in day-to-day tasks so we
took the base 2019 MacBook Pro with a
256 gigabyte SSD upgrade and compared it
to the $1,800 models matching 256 gig
SSD which has around a thousand
megabytes per second faster read speeds
at 2600 megabytes per second instead of
1,600 on the BassPro our first test was
a simple restart test which has to read
and load up all the system files to
start up and the base macbook pro was
only a few seconds behind
we then loaded up two identical
libraries in Final Cut Pro 10 and the
$1,800 MacBook was again just slightly
faster we also opened up Lightroom
classic and saw exactly the same results
as before so it seems like opening apps
and starting up Mac OS is just slightly
faster going from 1600 to 2600 megabytes
per second read speed so in this case I
definitely take higher performance
instead of faster SSD speeds so we moved
on to seeing if we can max out the SSD
speeds during heavy workloads using
Final Cut Pro and Lightroom and then
opening up the Activity Monitor to see
how much data was being read or written
per second and throughout all of our
testing we didn't see it go higher than
87 megabytes per second that's nowhere
near the maximum transfer speeds of even
the slower 2019 SSDs and the main reason
why we only saw a high of 87 megabytes
per second is because the storage has to
wait on the processor and graphics to
render and export the files which is
what you'll experience while using
basically every app out there we then
hooked up one of the most popular
external SSDs Samsung's t5 and
transferred large files to each MacBook
Pro to see which one finished first and
both took a
exactly the same time that's because the
MacBook SSDs can only transfer data as
fast as the connected device can
transfer data and most external SSDs
like the t5 are limited to only around
500 megabytes per second read and write
speeds and basically every flash drive
in every SD card reader even UHS - are
even slower than that
so you basically won't see any
difference in transfer speeds unless
you're using a top-of-the-line
Thunderbolt 3 external SSD which are
extremely expensive and if you're
willing to buy one of those and can
actually put the higher transfer space
to use you most likely will be buying a
higher-end macbook pro with even faster
SSD speeds the point I'm trying to make
is that most people who are in the
market for a budget oriented 13-inch
MacBook probably won't be able to max
out the speed of even the slower SSDs
that come on the new base models and
even though there is a small difference
in boot up speed and loading up apps the
base SSDs are more than fast enough
already
so if I had to choose between having
better processor performance extra
features or a cheaper price instead of
having a faster SSD I would sacrifice
the extra SSD speed every single time so
we've got to give props to Apple for
making this choice because getting $100
off the MacBook Air or getting much more
performance and features on the base
macbook pro for the same exact price is
well worth the slower SSD speeds that
most people in that market probably
won't use anyway and due to the amount
of users that commented on our videos
saying that they're finally going to
pick up a macbook thanks to the awesome
value the new base models pack we'd have
to say that the general public agrees
with us as well if this video helps you
make a decision to buy a new macbook
make sure to use those links down in the
video description below to help out our
channel thanks for watching and make
sure to tap that like button and click
the circle above to subscribe check out
one of those two videos right there and
we'll see you in the next video